citizens of the reject Nation Greg and
Coy here today John already left and
then Corner we were we're gonna go work
out together and then suddenly a a Blue
Beetle trailer came out and I was like
okay well let's just film this real
quick then before we got our secret
Invasion midnight show tonight koi I'm
glad you're here still uh how are you
feeling buddy uh pre-workout I'm very I
I was gonna hike with you and now we got
a Blue Beetle I have uh caffeinated and
I got creatine in my system so I am
pumped for this ladies and gentlemen
leave a like check out the other
trailers we already covered earlier this
morning let's see what's going on
I am real quick before we're going to
the trailer uh sdcc uh Comic-Con panel
Saturday July 22nd one o'clock P.M if
you guys are going to Comic-Con please
go check out our panel would love to
talk to you afterwards or before who
knows we don't really play by the rules
come back be there
[Music]
I want to play
it's dutch angle blue tracksuit
you've got to force it to come out what
do you
you're a genius I know like what'd I say
laughs
nice nice work suit is gorgeous oh did
you know what was going to happen to my
brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate he has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
who said that systems
oh yeah
overreacting
and drinking post-production
oh God every time it's great
eliminated
Deadpool eye vibes
the government is gonna do
correct yeah
the world with the power of the Scarab
it belongs to me what is she powering
oh he's pissed let's see it
indestructible there it is
[Applause]
nice
oh that was great
I swear
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal anything
please
that's more like it
I got chills man
for your family makes makes you weak
you're wrong
yes good to generic hero line oh I
forgot how bad it was
it's a family
oh
we saw the Aunt May moment
come on
[Laughter]
I advise
Batman is the fastest
let's not forget the line that broke
feet
that wasn't in this one they made sure
George Lopez
you know what man I oh god with
everything that's been happening with DC
lately and you know I know we're
transitioning to the DCU James going to
stated that the Blue Beetle will be the
first character in the DCU the first
official movie will be Superman Legacy I
really hope this does well because the
first trailer was good really good I
thought this was a great trailer this
was really really great it gave me
chills indestructible man while like
having a little bit of like some cliches
who gives a alright it looks
awesome uh but cholo looks incredible
and the cast looks so fun I'm really
really rooting for this one I I I it's
DC such an underdog right now and I am
really rooting for this film dude I
actually if this was a different trailer
it might have been like we should still
work out like I came back like there's
something about this movie he's the
underdog and this the studio is the
underdog right now like if it wasn't a
Blue Beetle trailer I might have been
like gains though like this is a movie
that I want to do well personally
because I really like sholo it's a
studio that I really believe in it's a
property that I care about I love that
it ties into court Industries in a way
that's interesting because it looks like
karnax is going to be our like middle
bad with you know uh the bigger bad
behind the scenes Emperor Palpatine kind
of situation right right but I like that
he if they were the same age that'd be
like your Iron Man almost Iron Monger
relationship like that that you know
texture of things but since he's more of
a Spider-Man it allows what would have
maybe been like a Green Goblin situation
if they knew each other but I like that
it's like a stranger with similar powers
that doesn't identify with like this
moral code like I like when villains and
heroes uh are the antithesis of each
other and I like that he seems like he's
just a bad guy but sometimes that's what
I want in a Villain Like I don't want
him to be mustached worldly but I like
that it's just like no money and power
yeah I mean going off where you're
standing impression that I'm getting is
that Susan surround his character uh
Victoria cord who I believe is a sister
I think that's what they're going with
and that's the comic I just hope that's
what they stick with because Ted chord's
great yeah so uh I believe that she will
be more of the intelligent ruthless
business type of woman villain monologue
kind of lady Exposition and she'll be
the one who to deliver like all the
lines and goodies and then you'll get
more of like the silent badass muscle
yeah in car packs right and I love that
Susan Sarandon like she always brings
the gravitas to the roles and that
automatically makes the chords more
interesting because Ted cord is the
original Blue Beetle and I'm wondering
how much they're gonna play with the
legacy of Blue Beetle here because the
original Blue Beetle is a very different
character the original blue Beatles like
a buddy cop with Booster Gold the
original Beetle has like you know the
the billions and has a lot of those Iron
Man things but it looks like they're
doing a mix of like Iron Man meets the
Spider-Man suit with AI meets Deadpool
here this looks like a blend of a lot of
that young hero but also with some of
the more classic well classic now to the
MCU character percent so with Sigourney
Weaver playing the sister of the
original Blue Beetle I'm curious about
the Legacy because they also uh I don't
know if you saw the quote this week but
Show Low said that if you're a fan of
the DC Universe there will be other
characters you recognize here oh cool so
that to me is like James Gunn has said
it's the first DCU character we get a
DCU film with Superman but if someone
gets introduced here it might not just
be Blue Beetle that carries over that
intrigues me that that intrigues us all
koi I appreciate you saying all of that
but yeah man this movie overall it looks
like it actually looks great great
action has a great family Dynamic to it
was that the Nana at the end yeah that
was adorable can I say this movie looks
very expensive and I mean not in a good
way it looks expensive with a great
family Dynamic to it and I love that
because Jaime is such a young character
and they're leaning into the fact that
he is in a lot of ways the uh a
spider-man-esque Peter Parker s kind of
character except he really does have a
much or Spider-Man was a lot more of a
loner he's got a much you know tighter
family bond unit you know and to see
that especially with like a Latino based
kind of film yeah uh that's it's just so
smart and the physicality I love the
physicality of it being a practical suit
with an actor that has physicality like
he actually does martial arts he
actually moves well so I love that they
put much like Ryan Reynolds who's one of
the best mimes that doesn't get credit
for it he's got this fighting
physicality that since the suit is
practical you feel the weight of it and
I feel like that's really important and
what I miss about some of the later era
Spider-Man I think Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man got the most time in the suit
that felt like he got the spider
elements this looks like the fighting
elements from you know karate kid from
him being a martial artist really serve
the character even if it's just flying
around and you know what I also love
that it feels kind of refreshing about
this as so many movies nowadays I feel
like we kind of even when if it's a new
character we're introducing we kind of
skip over the origin aspect of it or
they like they set them up right away
and then we see some of their origin and
flashbacks or something I like that
we're just getting an origin story again
you know it's refreshing it's weird
because we don't get those that often
anymore and Superman isn't Gonna Be An
Origin movie because we have seen
Superman so many times so it's also kind
of nice that if this does well see it it
will be a thing where we get an origin
movie starts to DCU in a way yeah like
having an origin movie start the DCU
then having Superman a character we all
know that's kind of a beautiful twofer
yeah for sure for sure impressed I love
the trailer love this one a lot liked it
more than the last one guys what did you
think about it leave your nitpicks down
below is Batman a fascist uh subscribe
check us out at Comic Con we're gonna
have a panel Saturday July 22nd at 1pm
and Cory and I we gotta go work out so
we'll see you guys soon thanks for being
here guys bye
thank you